[Music]
[Applause]
let's go to Ross Tucker CBS Westwood one
color analyst and host of the Ross
Tucker football podcast can you help us
with this at all no you know why this is
unbelievable okay so I was down in a
Boca Raton because Saturday night for
CBS I called the UAB at FAU game and for
some reason Dan the only Channel with no
audio was Fox and Dan I'm a Phillies fan
who lives in central Pennsylvania and
had Penn State season tickets so watch I
watched the Phillies Astros with no
audio then I was watching Penn State
Ohio State no audio I didn't even know
the kid's name I just know that he had
pretty much the best game I've ever seen
a college defensive player have he
single-handedly beat Penn State Penn
State might have won if that kid didn't
make all those plays so I have in fact
that ingested audio the controversial
ingested audio is the first time I've
ever heard that kid name in my life
you can check him out at rosstucker NFL
he'll be calling the Eagles Texans on
Thursday night for Westwood One your
first half of the season MVP is
Josh Allen yeah I think it's pretty
clearly Josh Allen I think it's pretty
close to say who's in second okay
between Patrick Mahomes and Jalen hurts
but I think Josh Allen's been the best
player in the league so far he's
incredibly impressive no team feels like
they're more dependent on one player
than the bills with Josh Allen I know
Mahomes is fantastic but Dan Josh
Allen's their best running back I mean
he's their best runner of the football
they are heavily heavily reliant on him
which is good for the MVP vote bad
because I just wonder how healthy he'll
be later in the year and whether or not
it impacts his ability to either be out
there at all or just has his performance
suffer a little bit because he's still
taking more shots than he needs to and I
wondered about this when I'm watching
Green Bay I know they lost they lost by
10. but I saw positives there that they
did pretty well in the second half
against Buffalo they ran the football
I that's the team I thought we were
going to see this year run the football
play really good defense and then have
Rogers sprinkle in these young receivers
what do you think of the Packers moving
forward based off last night well they
do have a good defense I mean sometimes
they don't get the best results but they
have a lot of good players over there I
mean Kenny Clark rashan Gary jair
Alexander they have a very talented
defense I thought they did for the most
part pretty well holding Buffalo to 27
points but the offense 17 points is
still not going to cut it I mean I know
they ran the ball a little bit better
but it's kind of crazy to think about
how far we've lowered the bar for this
Packers offense with you and other
people feeling okay about the fact that
they scored 17 points in a Prime Time
game and the problem now is Dan they're
too far behind to win that Division I
mean they're going to have to battle
their fannies off just to get back and
get a wild card to even have a chance
that's what's different between them and
like the bucks or the Niners right the
Bucks and the Niners are still in my
mind the favorites to win their
divisions and town enough and have
enough of a playoff pedigree that once
they do they could do some serious
damage the Packers are going to have to
really battle just to get in the
tournament at all
you know you mentioned some of these
teams like San Francisco might have more
Talent skilled position was could you
think of another team that has more
Talent
at the skill position
um I I you know you might say I'm biased
because I do their preseason games on TV
the Eagles are pretty loaded then I was
actually at the game yesterday which I
never get to do after doing the pregame
show I tailgated which is amazing I I
wish I could quit all my jobs and become
a full-time Tailgater and then I sat in
the stands with my wife
you know AJ Brown three touchdown
catches of over 25 yards in the first
half Jalen hurts I just referenced
earlier is playing an MVP caliber level
maybe just a notch behind Josh Allen
Milo Sanders having an awesome year
Dallas Goddard is a top five tight end
in the NFL their number two receiver
Devonte Smith's a really good player I
mean I think because the Eagles o-line
is so good and the d-line to some extent
that their skill guys almost get
overshadowed but they have a really good
group as well yeah but I look at the
Niners now you have McCaffrey there Debo
IU you have uh George Kittle you know
it's Jimmy G where you're just not sure
it feels like if they're going to win
it's going to be because of him and if
they don't win it'll be because of him
is that fair like how many quarterbacks
do you say that about if we win it's
probably going to be because of you not
making mistakes and if we lose it'll be
because you did make mistakes
well I mean I think that's probably the
case for like the bills and the chiefs
with Josh Allen and Mahomes if those
guys make the difference is I think
between those guys and Jimmy G that
you're getting to Dan or you're getting
it is that rarely do Josh Allen and
Mahomes seemingly make those mistakes
right it feels like Jimmy G is more up
and down and that the team goes with the
temperature of him and he's had some
really good playoff runs and he's had
some bad games but they looked really
impressive yesterday and the key I think
Dan they ran the offense through
McCaffrey right
when they had Debo they would run the
offense through him a lot but these guys
get banged up both of them get banged up
now Shanahan has two guys in case one of
them is not 100 damn that he can really
run the offense through and make them
the focal point I mean 18 carries almost
100 yards eight catches including that
awesome touchdown catch I mean he would
be I think McCaffrey I would like to go
through it someday and see how many
teams I think McCaffrey would be the
starting slot wide receiver for because
I think it's probably at least a handful
Dallas improves to six and two
and you know now we're seeing a team
that they can play defense and uh you
know eventually they'll realize that
Tony Pollard is the better running back
but hey who am I
um how
if you're looking at the top three so
you go Buffalo Philadelphia Kansas City
I'm going to guess is Dallas the next
team
on that hierarchy yeah I think they are
I think they are especially if they
realize like you just stated which has
been obvious to the rest of us for a
couple years they're a better team
without Zeke I mean they're a better
team when Pollard gets more snaps
because of how explosive he is I am very
curious to see what Zeke's usage will be
like when he comes back and my guess is
they'll make sure he's super duper 100
before he comes back but the way Dak
played yesterday you know running a
little bit some of the throws he made
when Dax playing like that they are the
fourth best team and they could compete
with the top three I mean they are right
there because of the way their defense
makes plays I mean Parson gets a
touchdown I think the Cowboys are right
there and I'm surprised I did not think
that they would be with some of the guys
they lost like Amari Cooper and
obviously Tyron Smith injury Lyle
Collins to since Cincinnati Randy
Gregory it's impressive what the Cowboys
are doing we're talking to Ross Tucker
CBS Westwood one color analyst host of
the Ross Tucker football podcast we know
the rule DJ Moore knows the rule you
can't take off your helmet during a
celebration
what do you do with a penalty like this
that that was poor you know pure
exuberance on his part
but an immature moment so spontaneity
took his helmet off and you know it cost
you cost you dear you know what's
interesting the whole rule was designed
because it didn't want to be about the
guys every guy as soon as they score a
touchdown taking their helmet off and
showing attention to themselves drawing
attention themselves right like the
taunting thing is they just don't want
you to do something directly to an
opponent because that's a bad example
for the for the other leagues the lower
levels of football college high school
Etc it's the same thing with the helmet
rule they didn't want to start this
where every time a guy scores a
touchdown they hit the helmet off to get
the TV time and next thing you know you
got Pop Warner kids and everybody making
it about them rather than the team the
thing the word you used I thought was
interesting Dan is exuberance because I
don't really think it was DJ Moore
trying to draw attention to himself in
terms of like give me TV time I think he
was literally that excited because I've
known him since he was in high school
watching him play high school football
he's never done it in college he's never
done it in the NFL I mean he clearly
knows the rule I think he just lost his
mind and I can tell you there's been a
couple times when I've been on a
football field where the energy is such
that you almost like Black out I mean
it's so loud and the moment was so
significant that you kind of black out
and it's like 10 seconds later you're
like what the heck just happened and I
think DJ Moore had a blackout moment
because he kind of realized it right
away I hated to see it called but I knew
it was going to be called because it was
such an incredible play an incredible
pass and then I thought oh okay well are
they going to take the penalty on the
extra point or on the kickoff and they
wisely took it on the extra point and
and sent Pinero back because they did
their research and they realized the
numbers certainly going to be in their
favor that he might shank this and
turned out to be correct it's funny too
because if Pinero makes that kick or the
kick in overtime we're not even really
talking about it that much right I mean
maybe you mentioned it casually but it
doesn't become a huge deal like it's
become I mean I don't think Steve Wilkes
has a great chance to get the long-term
job and full-time job in Carolina anyway
but hey you win that game then you've
won two in a row as the interim you
start to get some momentum then you
never know
well these guys you know he wants to win
so that helps their uh helps his
situation there if they lose you know
they they want to get a higher pick here
you know so I think you're going to have
that mixed emotions with some of these
managerial tanking later in this season
it's great to talk to you as always
Eagles Texans uh Thursday night for
Westwood one he's Ross Tucker host of
the Ross Tucker football podcast thank
you Ross thanks Dan